hold on hold on let me just uh show of
hands here it's 200 pounds uh nothing to
you guys so raise your hand of 200
pounds if the investment goes right it's
great if it doesn't go right okay if one
is 200 pounds of nothing so none of
these men are men
they're of course they're men but
there's different calibers of men okay
they're they're not they're not the
right caliber yeah what's the caliber
yeah what's the caliber what's that
about no but I'm I just know you know I
have a certain type of mind like I like
a man that's you know I wanna I wanna I
want a man that's like a leader in a
high position that can teach me because
I want to be in that place too so and
you're willing to show with nothing no I
listen like I said 200 pounds ain't
nothing to a man you could show him
everything and he will just and he could
possibly not be serious with you and be
speaking to another girl or sleeping
with someone else and that's the that's
the only reason